in this video we will share some good
news with you we finally have external
primary server that will allow you to
migrate your MySQL server to Google
cloud platform with minimal downtime we
know there are two ways to migrate data
and this talk talks about both but shows
you the new feature the replication from
an external primary into called cycle
the traditional way involves a variable
downtime migration which could take from
minutes to hours or even weeks depending
on the size of your data this approach
usually have the following configuration
first an instance of your database your
primary needs to disconnect from your
application so the data doesn't change
then export this data to a SQL file or
CSV using tools like my C code up or PG
done after that provision a new instance
and import a file export it to this new
server at this point connect to the
application again so the downtime is
over if you can't afford a downtime this
is the simplest way of doing a database
migration if you can't afford that much
downtime there is a different way using
replication on this approach your
application is connecting to an instance
your primary and all the changes are
being set to a new instance of replicas
elsewhere replication will catch up but
you need to stop the application from
continuing writing to the existing
instance once that is completed the
replication is also stopped and the new
instance is promoted to be the new
primary with the promotion process
completed you can now point your
application to read and write to the new
instance watch the session and don't
miss out this feature in action watch as
I migrate the database from a single
instance within a common scenario
running a wordpress application with
apache and mysql to a new scenario where
the database is fully managed by called
sequel leaving the previous instance you
only serve the application
for more interchanges details check out
the full talk and follow the steps also
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for more great next rewind content
you
[Music]